[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'américains qui tente
d'échapper à leur angoisse celle de la
fin du monde
pour exorciser leurs peurs certains sont
allés s'installer loin de tout au beau
milieu des collines noir du dakota du
sud
sally moore vit seule avec ses deux
chiens
cet ancien informaticienne autrefois
citadine semble très à l'aise dans ce
vaste domaine forestier
j'apprends énormément avec cet endroit
en l'entretenant en faisant les choses
tout seul je me sens un peu comme un
enfant de 13 ans essaie de réparer des
choses n'y arrive pas et c'est encore
vous sentez plus en sécurité ici en 1999
sally été nettement moins sereine elle
pensait être à la veille d'une
catastrophe qui allait mettre le monde à
feu et à sang
retour à san diego c'est ici dans ce
quartier résidentiel que vis à limours
elle est informaticienne et mieux que
quiconque est persuadé qu'on ne pourra
pas échapper au bug de l'an 2000 alors
elle anticipe
depuis six mois je fais des réserves
d'argent liquide en petites coupures
au cas où les distributeurs de billets
ne marche plus
aussi les magasins ne prennent plus les
cartes bleues ça ce sont des billets de
1 dollar et 5 dollars vous voyez je fais
des paquets de 20 puis de sang ça ce
sont des pièces de 25 cents
cachés dans des boîtes de smarties ça je
suis très contente d'avoir trouvé cette
radio pour la faire marcher on n'a
besoin ni de piles ni d'électricité
et il y à une manivelle derrière vous la
remontée comme ça grâce à ça je peux
rester à l'écouté des informations
pendant les événements pendant leur
déroulement le 31 décembre le 1er
janvier aujourd'hui les gens achètent
des armes et la plupart ne savent pas
s'en servir si les gens paniquent cela
va devenir effrayant peut-être la garde
nationale décidera de nous mettre dans
des camps de travail
je n'en ai aucune idée quand salir voit
aujourd'hui ses images elle sourit
car dans la nuit du 31 décembre au 1er
janvier 2000 il ne s'est absolument rien
passé
elle se souvient de s'être couché tôt
cloîtré au beau milieu de ses réserves
de nourriture
[Musique]
je dois dire que lorsque je me suis
réveillé j'étais effaré l'électricité
fonctionnait mon réveil a marché je n'en
revenais pas j'évite allumé la télé pour
voir quel désastre avait frappé le monde
dans la nuit et puis rien salle il admet
aujourd'hui elle était déçue alors
puisque rien n'avait changé pour les
terriens
elle au moins les changer de vie quitter
la ville pour la campagne
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'au fond de moi j'espérais
qu'il allait se passer quelque chose qui
m'auraient permis d'utiliser tout ce que
j'avais appris ensuite je me suis mise à
la recherche d'un mode de vie qui me
convenait et j'ai atterri ce se
débrouiller avec peu de chose en pleine
nature
sally s'y préparer déjà en 1999
c'est lee moore et sa fille se sont
inscrits à des cours de survie en forêt
ou comment réapprendre les gestes de
l'homme de néandertal
les séminaires ont lieu tous les
week-ends et bien sûr ils sont payants
bienvenue à tout le monde à notre stage
basique numéro trois informaticiens
employés chef d'entreprise hippie la
clientèle de ces stages est très
diversifiée un seul point commun les
réunit la conviction que la fin de notre
civilisation et prochaine les gens qui
sont ici aujourd'hui sont persuadés que
l'an 2000 est un phénomène qui va
changer leur style de vie et leur place
dans la société
ils ont décidé d'apprendre comment on
vivait autrefois comment fabriquer leurs
vêtements et leurs décèle qu'il faut
faire c'est gratter tout doucement et
pas taper dessus comme ça là si la peau
était un peu plus grand vous pourriez
prendre appui dessus et faire coach
voyez ça c'est ce qu'on essaie d'enlever
ces petites fibres là mais il faut faire
attention faut y aller doucement
ce qu'il faut c'est enlever cette petite
fille une couche blanche
si dans notre civilisation la lumière si
tard c'est la fin on retourne à l'âge de
pierre sang toute cette électricité
notre style de vie sain et on retourne
sur deux on va se retrouver à utiliser
des choses comme ça on oublie
onze ans plus tard nous avons retrouvé
les deux instructeurs de ce stage tom et
suzanne
sur les collines non loin de san diego
il habite dans cette maison qui l'ont
fabriqué eux-mêmes
au premier abord ils semblent eux aussi
avoir pris du recul
tu avait les cheveux longs ma chérie et
toi tu n'avais pas de cheveux gris tu as
vu comme tout le monde avait l'air
sérieux ils pensaient qu'ils allaient
tous mourir mais nous on les aurait
sauvé tu te souviens du sort du
réveillon
on était si un patient on était sur
balcon on écoutait la radio
oui je me souviens et on écoutait le
passage à l'an 2000 de traverser tous
les créneaux horaires et puis il ne se
passait rien toujours rien et on a fini
par s'endormir
oui on s'est dit bon on a toujours de
l'électricité tout va bien à lons de
coucher et le lendemain matin 8 heures
mon père a téléphoné il m'a dit vous
êtes les deux seules personnes qui se
serait réjoui
si tout s'était arrêté mais qui sont
tout de même contente que rien ne se
soit passé bonne année
après on est devenus des parias
des parias car après le non évènement du
1er janvier 2000 ils se sont sentis
montré du doigt ridiculisés leurs
activités de cours de survie s'est
effondré avant de reprendre petit à
petit
mais
si les coaches plaisante aujourd'hui de
leurs peurs d'hier allez venez faire un
tour dehors il ne faut pas croire qu'il
soit devenu détendu et optimiste il se
prépare à l'imminence d'une nouvelle
catastrophe l'an 2000 n'était qu'une
date est notre vision des choses n'a pas
changé tous les jours je me demande
comment cette société fonctionne encore
nous avons tellement de gens sur terre
maintenant est de moins en moins de
ressources
je suis persuadé qu'il va bientôt se
passer quelque chose mais je ne sais pas
encore quoi je ne sais pas
regardez le pôle nord qui est en train
de fondre les populations qui deviennent
de plus en plus folle les bombes à
hydrogène les terroristes tiab ce qui
s'est passé au japon
les inondations dans notre pays j'ai
l'impression que le tempo des
catastrophes s'accélère aucun expert ne
confirme que les catastrophes naturelles
ou non font plus de morts qu autrefois
qu'importe tom et suzanne se prépare au
cas où ils vivent déjà en autarcie
le coach nous emmène à la cave où ils
entassent des produits alimentaires à
très longue conservation
ça c'est des rations militaires du
poulet avec du riz on a aussi du port on
en a au moins 1000 comme ça j'ai acheté
50 de tee-shirts
j'ai cinq paires de chaussures ce sont
des haricots sécher ici toujours du riz
à d'autres fayot et de la nourriture
pour le chien peut-être qu'il y aura des
gens qui viendront défoncé notre porte
pour tous nous piquer c'est pas grave
car tout ça n'est qu'une petite partie
de notre réserve le reste il ne le
trouveront pas tout ça c'est les couches
et des couches de paranoïa peut-être
mais c'est un investissement sur
l'avenir
le plus étonnant n'est pas à la cave
l'instructeur nous emmène sur le terrain
qui entoure sa maison
depuis des années il y en terre des
centaines de containers de nourriture il
y en a partout là à perte de vue
j'ai 35 tonnes de nourriture enterré sur
mon terrain par là et puis par la tiens
voilà une bouteille qui me trahis
voyez elle sort de terre c'est de la
nourriture pour les poules du maïs et du
millet en tout cas si vous trouvez
quelque chose dans un coin vous ne
pourrez pas tous découvrir cela sera
impossible l'humanité pourrait
redémarrer ici c'est ce que je laisse
aux générations futures
ils n'auront pas se préoccuper de la
nourriture pendant très longtemps
milan milan si tout va bien un peu plus
haut sur la colline
tom découvre une bouteille qui a été
dévoré par des coyotes
[Musique]
les sales bestioles ils sont malins ces
animaux
autre élément de survie indispensable
l'eau là aussi
tom a tout prévu avec plusieurs
containers répartis aux quatre coins de
sa propriété vous voyez avec ce
container je récupère le plus qui vient
du toit vous rêvez d'être le dernier
homme sur terre j'adorerais être le
dernier homme sur terre le dernier homme
vivant c'était comme brise les des
hommes comme tom on les appelle les
survivalistes ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux aux états unis à phoenix en
arizona
voici jiming un ancien agent de sécurité
divorcer le bug jim n'y a jamais cru
mais aujourd'hui il pense qu autre chose
va bientôt anéantir la planète
c'est un fait la terre change c'est un
fait il y a de plus en plus de
catastrophes naturelles
jusque dans toute l'histoire de notre
pays notre planète terre arrive à la fin
de son cycle de trois mille ans et elle
nous fait comprendre qu'elle en a marre
et qu'elle va bientôt faire le ménage
cette théorie catastrophiste jim les a
découvertes avec hollywood
il a vu the day after tomorrow ou encore
2012 le film de roland emmerich le
scénario reprend une croyance maya qui
prédit la fin du monde au mois de
décembre 2012
en cause des plaques tectoniques qui se
mettraient à glisser et provoquerait de
multiples séismes
le cinéma et internet ont déchaîné
l'imagination de jim
j'ai fait des recherches sur internet et
découvert plein de prédiction qui
coïncide avec 2012 le pape à rome les
chrétiens d'autres religions il ya les
prédictions au pis les mayas et enfin
des prophéties de gens comme nostradamus
ou edgar cayce ses prédictions
proviennent de communautés qui n'ont
rien en commun
comment se fait-il que tout cela arrive
à la même date
moi je pense qu'il risque de se passer
quelque chose une chose est certaine
jim quittera phoenix en novembre
prochain plusieurs semaines avant la
date fatidique
une fuite ce qu'ils préparent
soigneusement depuis des années en cas
de catastrophe majeure
j'ai d'abord une première planque dans
une grotte dans laquelle je resterai
quelques temps pas plus d'un mois
ensuite je me rendrai dans un deuxième
site beaucoup plus éloigné un endroit où
je pourrai recréer une nouvelle
civilisation
la grotte est situé à une demi heure de
chez lui à 1000 mètres d'altitude
la voici il a enterré des vivres tout
autour comme tom le coach les
survivalistes ont tous en commun ce
réflexe d'écureuils cette grotte
l'ancien agent de sécurité s'attend à
devoir la défendre il est persuadé
qu'après la grande catastrophe de
décembre prochain
l'humanité va s'entretuer
après la catastrophe
attendez trois à sept jours et ça va
être l'anarchie dans les rues vous allez
peut-être devoir vous battre avec
beaucoup de gens qui tenteront de vous
voler vos vivre ils ne vont plus
respecter la loi il n'y aura plus de
règles il n'y aura rien pour les arrêter
et ils n'hésiteront pas à vous tuer
d'abord il vous faut un fusil 223 ça
c'est les munitions c'est ce que les
militaires utilisent aujourd'hui dans
l'armée américaine
c'est une carabine 22 mm c'est pour la
chasse mais vous pouvez aussi l'utiliser
pour la défense enfin ça c'est un
pistolet 45 mm vous voyez ces balles
elle vous travers ces fonds un trou de
la taille d'une pomme à la sortie
la deuxième planque de jim est à deux
heures de voiture
pas question de filmer les panneaux sur
le trajet notre survivalistes redoutent
que sa propriété soit localisé vous
voyez on monte et ça c'est un gros
avantage
je ne dis pas nécessairement qu'une
vague géante va recouvrir tout l'ouest
du pays
mais dans le doute je préfère être au
sommet d'une montagne pour finir la
route
il faut poursuivre en quad
[Musique]
et voici la propriété une vieille
caravane sur un terrain rocailleux de 6
hectares une mine abandonnée ou jim à
cacher de quoi nourrir cinq personnes
pendant deux ans dit il ensuite il
faudra chasser il y a plein de reptiles
et d'autres bestioles vous êtes dans le
besoin vous pourrez toujours manger ça
il ya aussi plein d'oiseaux
depuis des années jim entassent des
matériaux de construction
un bric à brac qui lui permettra
d'édifier ce qu il m appelait son arche
de noé
j'ai quelques personnes qui viendront me
rejoindre des survivalistes comme moi
des gens que j'ai envie d'avoir avec moi
dans ce genre de situation quoi qu'il
arrive je serai capable de survivre et
je m'en donne les moyens
je ne vais pas rester chez moi en ville
et attendre que mes réserves de
nourriture s'épuisent sans savoir où
aller
moi j'ai l'ultime solution retour à son
domicile principal
pour financer son projet jim à monter un
commerce d'articles de survie sur
internet 2012 pour lui a commencé très
fort déjà à la proche de la fin 2011
mais ventes de produits de survie ont
augmenté de 30 % en 2012 à partir de
février mars elles ont encore doublé
les gens se préparent car ils pensent
qu'il se passera quelque chose en 2000
sur ce marché de la peur certains sont
aux avant postes comme la société vive
hausse dont voici une publicité sur fond
de requiem
on y apprend que notre temps est compté
qu'une catastrophe planétaire est
imminente
en fait vive hausse est une société
immobilière qui vend des bunkers
souterrains racheter à l'armée
américaine
[Musique]
il s'agit de base désaffectée datant de
la guerre froide
[Musique]
le remplacement est tenu secret
ces abris ultra blindés pourrait
recevoir trois mille réfugiés affirme la
société
deux mille personnes auraient déjà
investi
au coeur du désert au sud de la
californie
nous avons rencontré un acheteur
employés dans le syndicat des
camionneurs de la région jim hodge a
découvert les bunkers vive hausse en
lisant son journal
il a payé le sien 25000 dollars sur ses
économies
[Musique]
je suis allé sur leur site internet
j'ai tout de suite été séduit par
l'offre mais très vite j'ai postulé et
décidé d'investir pour moi et surtout
pour ma famille comme de nombreux
clients de vive hausse
jim est persuadé que 2012 est l'année de
l'apocalypse à cause d'un dérèglement
géologique
[Musique]
une force magnétique qui va dérégler la
polarité de la planète
il ya beaucoup de scientifiques qui on
parle
il pense que cela va se passer en 2012
qu'importe si la nasa dément
formellement cette hypothèse tout comme
celle d'un astéroïde percutant la terre
notre syndicaliste se félicite d'assurer
à sa fille un avenir sécurisé dans un
bunker vive hausse t'inquiète pas c'est
nous on sera en sécurité
et c'est là qu'on valait oui dans l'abri
et il est où il est dans l'indiana une
fois aménagé l'abri de jim sera tout
confort comme le promettent ces images
de synthèse je pense que vive hausse et
le meilleur de mes investissements
l'abri tout près nous aurons deux
réserves de nourriture de vêtements tout
ce qu'il faut pour la famille on a à
s'inquiéter de rien notre seul job c'est
d'arriver la barre à terre
et pour faire les 3000 kilomètres de
trajet entre la californie et l'indiana
jim a tout prévu il s'est acheté une
énorme caravane 48 dollars de plus il
l'a remplira avec des rations de guerre
actuellement caché là encore dans un
endroit secret voilà ma deuxième maison
il nous faudra trois jours pour
atteindre la bride vivons nous aurons
tout ce qu'il faut dans ce cas regardez
ma fille vous montrer quelque chose
n'est pas parce que c'est la fin du
monde qui ne faut pas rester vaut le
business de la survie ne vise pas
seulement les particuliers
il s'adresse aussi aux entreprises
nous sommes chez qualcomm leader
américain de la fabrication de
téléphones portables aujourd'hui les
employés sont conviés à une conférence
sur la survie en cas de catastrophe les
professeurs ne sont autres que les
coaches tom et suzanne qui ont trouvé
ici un nouveau débouché professionnel
les chiens sont du voyage aller regardes
tu as tous à l'espace pour toi je vous
présente suzanne et hommes
vous ne pouvez pas compter uniquement
sur le gouvernement pour vous venir en
aide
n'est ce pas nous pouvons devenir
autonome adapté et prendre notre destin
en 1999 tom apprenez à ses élèves à
faire du feu à l'aide de simples bouts
de bois et d'une ficelle aujourd'hui le
même résultat est obtenu à l'aide d'une
pile et de laine de verre
[Musique]
pendant une heure trente les employés
vont apprendre à se chauffer à purifier
l'eau mettre de la nourriture en
conserve le clos de la présentation une
lampe à huile fabriqué avec une pomme de
terre et un bout de tissu
et voilà ça va brûler temps qu'il reste
de l'huile dans la patate
la conférence est diffusé sur l'intranet
de qualcomm
afin d'atteindre un maximum de salariés
l'investissement peut paraître étrange
pas pour la direction bien sûr qu'ils
aient raison économique derrière cette
formation ce qu'il s'est passé lors de
l'ouragan katrina
les employés à la rue qui ont été
obligés de quitter la région
les entreprises paralysées etc nous on
se dit qu'un employé bien préparés
reviendra plus vite au travail
comme quoi le survivalisme peut avoir
des applications très rationnel
après l'an 2000 plus personne ne voulait
entendre parler de survivalisme à cause
de toutes les bêtises qui avait été dit
sur le bug
maintenant notre nouveau stage s'appelle
survivre un désastre dans un milieu
urbain
mais vous savez c'est le même principe
dehors ou dedans ce qu'il vous faut pour
survivre c'est de l'eau de la chaleur et
de la nourriture
le stage se termine et apparemment il a
beaucoup plu nous allons doubler nos
effectifs dans la baie de san francisco
ça vous dirait d'aller former nos
employés là bas chéri il s'agit d'aller
à san francisco - ok super ça va être
formidable
à la veille du troisième millénaire les
paranoïaques du bugue n'étaient pas les
seuls à prédire des bouleversements
planétaires
certains chrétiens conservateurs
annonçait eux aussi l'apocalypse pour
l'an 2000 aujourd'hui ils l'annoncent
pour 2012 et ils font des conférences
pour le prouver
ce séminariste a établi des liens entre
les catastrophes naturelles et les
textes de la bible le nombre de
tremblements de terre a tellement
augmenté
il a doublé triplé les prophéties sont
en train de se réaliser sous nos yeux
écoutez ce que disait saint mathieu bout
livrer des guerres
il y aura des famines des tremblements
de terre
le démon un peu partout ce ne sera que
le début des malheurs
je pense que nous sommes très proches de
la fin du monde ça a commencé en 2011
cela se poursuivra en 2012 et culminera
à la fin de l'année quelque chose de
soudains et cataclysmique notre monde a
presque 7000 ans et jésus va bientôt
nous ramener à la maison
c'est pour bientôt
dans l'assistance le pasteur denning
nous l'avions rencontré en 1999 dans sa
paroisse en attendant le troisième
millénaire
la petite communauté baptiste diggle
l'est se serre les coudes
l'église du village leur sert de lieu de
rencontre à longueur de cérémonie on y
dissèque les textes bibliques censé
annoncer la fin du monde
un mélange de mysticisme et de crâne
ancestral la même peur qu'il ay à milan
au passage du deuxième millénaire
[Musique]
marc gales personnellement je crois du
fond de mon coeur que dieu va revenir en
amérique pour le jugement dernier
l'amérique est une nation qui a oublié
dieu et je crois que l'amérique va
devoir faire face à la colère de dieu
quelle qu'en soit la forme
nous attendons donc avec impatience le
retour de jésus-christ qui va peut-être
revenir en l'an 2000 nous le retrouvons
dans la maison familiale où il vit avec
sa femme et leurs neuf enfants
[Musique]
au regard de ma vieille moustache
regarde notre vieille camionnette au
regarde amanda lindhout
finalement pas d'apocalypse pas de
retour de jésus
une déception qui semble difficile à
admettre aujourd'hui
non on ne peut pas dire que nous étions
déçus use
nous considérons que c'est dieu qui
décide et que tôt ou tard il passera à
l'action
parce qu'ils pensent que cette fois
l'apocalypse est imminente
le pasteur denning continue de prier
chaque soir avec ses filles et quand il
parle ensemble de religion le thème de
la mort revient souvent dans leurs
conversations
alors partons du principe que tout va se
dérouler comme nous le prévoyons si
quelqu'un frappe à la porte et te dis
soit hurni jésus-christ soit je tabac ou
jab à tes parents
qu'est-ce que tu réponds si j'aime
vraiment dieu je réponds non tu ne
reniera pas le seigneur tu dis toujours
que c'est plus facile de mourir pour lui
que de vivre pour lui ah oui c'est vrai
dernière étape chez ceux qui attendent
la fin du monde
les membres d'une arius une arius est
une secte basée à san diego
elle a été fondée dans les années 50 par
lous norman depuis ses adeptes se
prépare à l'arrivée de ce qu'elle a
surnommés les space brothers les frères
de l'espace pour mieux s'en convaincre
il avait réalisé cette vidéo dans les
années 70
[Musique]
en 1999 il attendait un grand événement
la première chose à laquelle les gens
pensent quand on parle de l'an 2000
c'est quoi le bug informatique et tout
le monde ne parle que de ça moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui va se passer
juste après l'an 2000
et qu'est ce qui va se passer exactement
l'atterrissage de soucoupe volante sur
la planète terre en l'an 2000
l'espèce brothers ne sont pas venus à
cause de la violence de la race humaine
selon kevin la taxe sur les états unis
par al qaïda et puis toutes les autres
guerres partout dans le monde
spirituellement nous ne sommes pas assez
mûr pour ces êtres venus d'une autre
planète
il aimerait bien venir mais on les en
empêche petite consolation leur
président david reynolds aurait eu droit
à une visite privée de l'une des
soucoupes volantes d'espèces brothers
j'ai fait un tour sur un vaisseau
spatial
lorsqu'il était dans notre atmosphère
ils m'ont fait visiter le vaisseau et
j'ai pu rencontrer leurs scientifiques
espèces brothers nous ressemble mais ils
sont plus grands et leurs visages sont
illuminés
[Musique]
chaque semaine les membres d'une arius
continue de se réunir afin de
communiquer en chansons avec l'espèce
brothers
désormais leurs meetings sont
retransmises sur internet les suivis par
leurs adeptes partout dans le monde
quant à l'atterrissage ils sont sûrs
qu'il se produira en 2012
[Musique]
à mon avis c'est pour bientôt peut-être
en 2012
tout le monde dit qu'il va se passer
quelque chose pourquoi pas l'arrivée
d'espèces brothers qui viendront servir
l'humanité
[Musique]
un atterrissage reporter une apocalypse
qui a pris du retard
après 2012 il y aura d'autres attentes
d'autres dates les astrophysiciens parle
déjà d'apophis l'astéroïde qui devrait
frapper la terre en 2029
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]